what's up y'all I'm Phantom and this is
the wired autocomplete
interview I wanted to get a face T but
all my friends kept saying don't do that
y'all let me know if I should but I
don't know everybody keep saying don't
do it so
whatever all right what does phom mean
it's my nickname basically uh you know
like a cast like a ghost like phom like
he just I'm in and out I'm just I just
show up what is been real name my real
name is Roberto you got say with a
little accent though cuz if you don't
say it with the accent you're not really
saying it at all what is phantom tax
Phantom tax is basically let's your
friend having a mail he's having a good
maal and you just want a piece of that
mail like you know what I'm saying you
need a share cuz that's your friend
friend share right get you a little
piece of the mail it's the phanom T you
just go ahead and just let me get a
little bit of 5% 10% of the meal maybe
20% just depend on how you feel that day
you know what I mean I know lately they
got the new thing they got the uh the
sticking at your G for the rler you're
so skiy you're so F I don't know what
that is but shout out to the little Bros
that that came up with that I don't know
what that is but that's the Phantom text
what server does Phantom play on oh GTA
5 district 10 join up you know what's
going on we just had fun on it everybody
else over there you know what's going on
what's phenom's favorite song I've Been
bumping F no ways by Drake DM near every
day I ain't going to lie but my favorite
song I Would yeah I I feel like it
changes every two three months so oh oh
oh matter of fact temp is dropped I
think it's me and you tough right now
I'm playing that every day too tough
what car does Phantom have so I'm going
to give you my favorite car my BMW M4
2018 competition Edition I'm talking
about we had fun with that you know what
I'm saying my other cars just cool shout
to the Hond boys Honda Accord you know
what I mean 2008 V6 and in my most
recent pickup I did like a wild body to
it my Lamborghini I did a widebody TST
stage two is fire but my favorite car my
BMW
M4 all right cool moving on phom and K
shout out to K Lynch That's the Bro oh
we used to do videos back in the Bronx
but she still the Bro to this day you
feel me Phantom and Duke Duke Dennis
Duke is the bro if you don't know about
you need to find out now is a group a
Content creation group and me and Duke
are a part of it along with K Davis uh
aent and Chris you know what I'm saying
so shout out to Duke Dennis the brosi we
go way back we've been playing 2K and
stuff on the game since I was like 16 so
yeah Phantom Deli order all right if you
ask me today my Del I might get a chop
cheese with everything on it turkey
bacon on it you know I'm try get little
you know what I mean lettuce tomato I
might do light mayo depending of the day
I might do a little bit of ketchup just
to get that twang in there but if I'm
feeling healthy I might do honey turkey
you know what I'm saying it depend you
know what I'm saying just different day
different moves right phom straight face
me I don't know I don't know what have
no idea what that is I don't know
Phantom straight face meme I'm not sure
I ain't gonna lie Phantom kylo Richmond
RP kylo Richmond that's my GTA 5
character he got shot somebody shot
him all right cool why does phom wear a
mask usually I wear ski mask on stream
as of recent only because I got this
little weight loss challenge cuz you
know what I'm saying they been telling
me like you got to do something about it
bro so I've been working on me and if I
get under 230 lbs which is been a little
tough know I mean cuz I like to eat good
uh I got to take off the mask but so far
I got to keep the mask school cuz I've
been going crazy why does phom say God
did cuz you know cuz God did you know
what I mean cuz God still doing um but
you know cuz God did it's
self-explanatory come on bro why does
phom steal food I don't steal food I add
i i i i i Implement my own tax cuz I
have to because as as a uh functionist
Society member whatever that's called
why are you buying food and not trying
to give nobody you should always offer
your friend you want some of this come
on bro like what are you talking
about all right bet when did phom join I
forgot the date but we started I was
there since day one since day Zero since
negative one matter of fact and what it
stands for any means possible so we just
feel like we going to get to where we we
got to get to by any means feel me so we
want to get 10 million subscribers on
YouTube maybe you should sub up you know
what I'm saying sub up to this channel
too you know what I'm saying like trying
to get up there when did Phantom grow up
the Bronx New York City you know what
I'm saying so I grew up on 167 well I've
been all over the Bronx but that's like
my final resting home you know what I'm
saying I got there when I was like 12
before that I was on 187 Marin a still
the Bronx it's just always been the
Bronx just the Big B A you know what I'm
saying the boogie down when did Phantom
start streaming I've been on and off
since I was a kid like on it on it
though like consistent I would say in
the past year and a half just been like
damn near almost every day but when I
first started my first ever stream with
the PlayStation camera if you know you
know you know what I'm saying that's
like 8 years ago 7 years ago that's that
was a little while ago where does phom
get his clothes it just depend you know
if you're a grill demon you know what
I'm saying or maybe the Bros might have
something you might want to trade or you
go thrift shopping I don't do too much
thrift shopping cuz I be in there for
too long and I start getting hungry and
I can't find my size and I got to go
home but um you know everybody different
online fall I don't know it just it just
you know whereever we find it at I could
chuck
it does
phom does Phenom have tattoos yeah I do
I got damn near my whole back flooded
out I wanted to get a face T but all my
friends kept saying don't do that y'all
let me know if I should but I don't know
everybody keep saying don't do it so
whatever can phom speak Spanish see
um it just makes sense like cuz it just
makes sense bro you feel me it's like
another saying that I say cuz it
definitely just makes sense you know
what I'm saying for sure you know what I
mean all right Phantom VR chat VR chat
is funny but it can get weird fast you
know that's like a you put the little
you know we in 2023 now you got
different stuff going on you know you
can do you do cool stuff fanom kick I
don't know what that means but I think
this is like the streaming platform you
know it's been an ongoing battle with
where streamers are signing to so far
I'm rocking with twitch you know what
I'm saying but you never know you know
what I'm saying you just never know I
can't speak too much on that but you
never know Phantom quotes uh damn whole
bunch of motivational stuff I'm always
saying some motivational cool stuff on
stream you know what I'm saying out of
nowhere at random it's never planned I
just get in that bag you got God did you
know what I'm saying you got shout out
to DJ K and no cap you feel me but where
went crazy with that one uh it just
makes sense a whole bunch of stuff you
know what I'm saying we just I can't
even name him off the top of my head you
got to tap in you got to tap in matter
of fact tap in tap in means get in tuned
that means you need to come yeah tap in
how about that when everybody spam tap
in Phantom in brown jacket remember I
was I was just saying a brown Jack
that's the only meme that I could say
that's a Phantom meme I ain't going to
lie they put it always like if someone
has food Phantom just ared and just put
they put that picture but that picture
is a funny picture I went to Walmart and
I got me a nice fit and I walked into
the crib with the fit and it was like
what what you got on but it look fly to
me it ain't about the brand bro how you
put it on bro like that bro I be trying
to say that y' be br
phom merch we got some merch dropping
you know shout out to the TR flick you
know what I'm saying we got some merch
right now we don't got no merch out but
you know we got some merch dropping so
word you know what I'm saying out
though. shop man you never know man go
tap in man facts but yeah this the last
one a man all right phantom phantom as a
kid like a picture or something what you
like as a kid I was just doing something
some random stuff I just like Off the
Wall Phantom GTA told y district 10 look
it up y'all district 10 man come on bro
come have fun with us bro you know we be
lit Phantom in Japan me and K went to
Japan we went to uh where we went to we
went everywhere Japan was super dope we
did IRL streaming if you don't know what
IRL streaming is all right some people
stream from the house others stream
outside in the world they just put the
camera on and it's like you know my
location 24/7 is a little creepy but
it's cool though so you know what I'm
saying my catches on Twitch and stuff
like that Phantom DP I don't know
garments and pieces outfits stuff like
that yeah oh that's all Google searches
right yeah damn why you trying to find
out about all that stuff bro what's up
with well I hope I answered your
questions that you had directly from the
source you know what I'm saying but yeah
phandom text stop top Googling that bro
like leave it
[Music]
alone